Ukraine's counteroffensive
is into its second month
and progress has been slow.
The challenges are vast.
Russia's war in Ukraine
is the world's
largest armed conflict
since World War Two.
This war is being fought on the ground
with traditional weaponry
like tanks and bullets.
But also in the skies
with newer technologies like drones.
A report in May found Ukraine was losing
more than 10,000 drones per month.
Well, my next guest says swarms of drones
are the future of war.
Eric Schmidt ran Google for many years,
but more recently advised the Pentagon
as the chair of the Defense
Innovation Board.
He now chairs
the special Competitive Studies Project,
a think tank focused on technology
and national security.
I should note,
I am a senior advisor to Schmidt Futures,
his philanthropic initiative.
Eric Schmidt pleasure to have you.
Good to be back.
So you were recently in Ukraine
and a lot of
your concerns stemmed from that
Let's first
just get a sense of the lay of the land.
What to you,
what does the battlefield look like?
Who has the advantage?
The thing that's shocking
is how big this war
is, 2000 kilometers long.
And since 2014,
the Russian
side has dug themselves in
in this horrific way.
So if you were a Ukrainian soldier
with your commander
saying go across this
five kilometer disputed area,
you'd have to get through the tanks.
The mines, the machine
guns, their drones.
You get to the other side,
you do your killing.
And then the back
part of Russia kills you.
It's an insurmountable task.
I was stunned
to read
how many shells the Russians are using.
60,000 a day The world
production in the West
can accommodate about 5000 a day.
I guess the Russians have been
building artillery for about 50 years.
And they have an infinite supply.
60,000 a day now.
I mean,
my math
is that you're talking about
something like 20 million a year.
Is too easy today.
This is a World War One, artillery war.
With people dug in.
How incredible.
100 years later,
we haven't come up with another way.
If you're the Ukrainians
trying to break through,
you want to get to the Sea of Azov.
You have to break through this
initial line
blows up reserve, for example,
and then you have to make a corridor.
Well, as you go through your corridor,
they're bombing you as well.
And now the bombing is precision bombing.
Right,
because you can target more accurately.
And the American doctrine
is that you would always do
such infantry moves with air power,
which the Ukrainians don't have.
And the air power comes
in, cleans the path,
and then the American gets
gets the other side running back,
and then they start to win.
We, meaning the Ukrainians,
the U.S.,
the West, need a solution
to get them moving.
So that gets us to drones.
They are already using
an extraordinary number of drones
the Ukrainians.
How many drones are they?
Are they using a week or a month?
They're on track to using a couple
hundred thousand drones in a year.
Most drones
only survive one or two flights
before they fail or they're blocked.
I was shocked
at how good
the Russians
were at electronic warfare and jamming,
basically everything
you send into this battlefield,
which is quite narrow, by the way,
the rest of the country is fine.
I suspect on both sides they jam.
Everything is jam
but also communications is jammed.
So normal drones don't work.
So the Ukrainians have
taken cheap Jones and added
additional antenna antennas.
One of things that I learned
was something called a kamikaze drone,
which is a $400 Chinese drone
that carries a small payload.
It moves so fast you can't shoot it down.
I had thought that
that was the innovation of the war.
To generals yesterday
told me that I'm wrong
and that what they really need
are cruise missile drones,
which can go really far
and carry with wings
and can carry more payloads.
I don't think
the Ukrainian drone strategy
is completely formed,
but they're building
a completely new theory of war
and this is where
we get to the solution for you.
The only way the Ukrainians
can break through
these lines
is with massive numbers of drones,
massive number of drones,
or massive number of human casualties
on both sides.
The beauty of the drone is
it can take out the other side's
military target
without collateral damage.
Right.
We are very concerned about the
the propagation
of this war against other countries,
but I'm very concerned
about its effect on civilians,
both the Russians and Ukrainians.
The important thing about a drone
is it's a very, very targeted solution.
It's very inexpensive.
I think
the goal that we should have for Ukraine
is to establish the principle
that there will never be another land war
where you can invade successfully,
that we're respecting the land.
The sovereignty of the land is important.
If you're mad at them, that's fine.
You can negotiate,
you can put pressure,
but you can't send artillery
and flattened cities,
which is what
the Russians have been doing.
How do you get
how do you
how do you get to the solution of
I mean, is
there can the Ukrainians produce
hundreds of thousands of drones?
They have the money
and they have the talent.
They haven't figured out
how to build all the factories yet.
And they have to be built in Ukraine
for many, many reasons.
So what I know is
there are about 60 companies
that are building these types of drones.
What's interesting is
it's just like startups
in the sense
that they're not particularly
well coordinated.
They're moving so quickly.
Remember, this is all a year old.
They're operating systems
and software aren't very integrated.
They can't speak to each other.
All the problems that you would imagine
now, if it were peacetime,
you'd have an overall strategy.
You get them organized and so forth.
What's interesting to me
is that this is both a broadband war,
but it's also
a technology war in the sense
that it's innovative
and innovation occurs in small companies,
not in the mode.
The Ukrainians were interesting.
I think you know as well
that the
Ukrainians set up
their drone operation
outside the military.
And the drone guy's name is Fedorov
is busy supplying them to the military,
but he controls the money.
He controls the strategy.
They told us that the biggest problem
they currently have
is that at the moment
they're taking these
tiny little essentially pipe bombs
and dropping them on to tanks.
And what they want is laser guided ones
or guided ones,
which is America's had for a long time.
They can follow the target.
Again, this is stuff
that America did 20 years ago
that they're just catching up on.
Did it does
does all this leave you
net, net, positive, optimistic?
I hate
to say it
but I
think this is going to go on
for a long time.
There's not enough advantage
on either side.
I don't think Russia will gain much land,
if any.
And I think the going
is so slow
to get across this danger
zone, this killing field,
that it will take a year or two.
Now, of course,
there could be breakthroughs.
There could be
Wagner could start running
and things like that that we don't
we don't understand.
But at the moment,
it's much more balanced
than the marketing says.
They talk about this counteroffensive,
which is certainly a great idea.
They're not ready to do
an American style.
100 million people,
you know, state, you know, full power.
They don't have the assets.
Furthermore,
if you put airplanes in the air,
they get shot down by Russian
surface to air missiles.
So it's a really hard problem.
One of my friends who was looking at
this strategically said,
You realize that the Russians
have been fighting this way
for 100 years? I said, Okay.
And he said,
that means that you have
to give them a hard problem to solve
the simple problems, like
do this and do that.
The other side is too sophisticated.
And the Russians
are clearly in this to win
Sobering, but but very smart.
Thank you. Eric Schmidt, thank you.